my job is in film is illustrator but
what that really means is you're a
concept designer so I'm a concept
designer in entertainment specifically
film which means I read the script I'm
given the task of designing a vehicle a
costume a character a monster a set and
you draw it paint it sculpt it in
certain cases and work with either
production designer or the director
themselves and because I do so much
stuff that is post-production related I
usually end up working with the visual
effects house that's doing the actual
post-production work my resume that i
think most people would recognize
obviously avatar Cloverfield then after
Cloverfield Star Trek and piranha 3d
Green Lantern 20,000 Leagues Under the
Sea there's a lot of productions that
start and then stop Tron super 8 and
most recently Ridley Scott's Prometheus
I think that the reason I'm desired on
certain productions is something I've
been told by different directors I tend
to be very thorough about the core
concept what the characters motivations
are so as opposed to designing something
that just looks menacing the byproduct
in the end the net result is that it has
to be that way but for me to get there I
like to understand why it's pissed off
why its aggressive oh why it's sentient
I'd like to understand if it is huge how
physiologically it could support its own
weight if it's a super 8 the creature is
is an underground creature its
subterranean so if it is that why what
is the motivation is it subterranean on
its planet or is it now subterranean on
this planet just for the purposes of
being discreet and I like to think
through all of that I think about it in
terms of an industrial designer
developing a consumer product which is
why when you look at Tron for example
Tron might seem a bit in Congress to the
work that I've done but if anything Tron
is more my wheelhouse because I'm a
trained industrial designer I work
professionally developing automotive
products medical products sporting goods
including helmets so that when i was
doing creature work specifically on
Avatar i applied all the same
methodology of industrial design to
creature which is form follows function
you have to be mindful of the physics of
the engineering behind something because
the navi road the banshee so you have to
think about center of gravity you have
to think about flight wing length chord
length all those things in which
greatest james cameron totally supports
and demands that you're that smart about
it i wish i could say more about
prometheus because i'm so excited having
worked at ridley scott in any capacity
is such an amazing thing kind of like
one of the best things ever for me just
being in the same room with somebody who
I consider a god in the genre film that
I like so much but he he he doesn't just
do sci-fi obviously he's done many types
of films but literally sitting in the
room with him talking about the
possibility of a prequel to alien was
just unbelievable now it's changed and
it's turned into prometheus which is why
I'm elusive about what the story is what
it's about is it alien is is Geiger
involved a lot of the stuff I simply
don't know
I wish I did I wish I did but I just
tell me actually i'll throw you a
curveball because the assumption is that
I'm designing characters and creatures
Prometheus when in fact on Tron the same
question Kim was like you're working on
Trent I'd no idea there were creatures
intron like wait until you see and i
wasn't i was designing costumes and
props so prometheus
who knows what I'm doing